hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to explain why i could guess
the card you were staring at
we start out with a set of five cards
you start out at the number one and that
really doesn't matter you could actually
start at any card in the trick
when you go through these moves
it actually doesn't matter
which way you move
which day of the month it is
the move which really matters is the
second to last move
that on an odd card you need to move
three times and on an even card you need
to move four times
the reason is that if you're on an odd
card
you're going to end up on an even card
and if you're on an even card you stay
on an even card so if you're on an odd
card one you can end up at the cards two
or four
if you're at three you'll end up at two
or four
and if you're at five you'll end up at
two or four
similarly on an even card you will
either end up from two you'll end up at
two or four
or from four you'll end up at two or
four
and the reason is an odd number plus an
odd number is an even number
and similarly an even number plus an
even number is an even number
so after this step
i can be completely certain that you are
either at the cards two or four
the final move is just to move left two
times
and if you're on the number two
you're gonna move to one and then back
to two
and if you're at four you get to two
so with certainty i can say you're at
the cartoon
and that's how the trick works
i hope you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can catch me on my vlog mind your
decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker or get my
ebooks at amazon